tiens alors la freine french touch c'est
aussi la garantie pur beurre au salon
des métiers de bouche c'est à lyon bien
entendu on a désigné les meilleurs
pâtissiers du monde ils sont français
un pâtissier de 3,1 glacier de tarbes et
un chocolatier de talloires virginie du
portique des supporters déchaînés des
photographes appliquée mais pas de
ballon de football ici s'affrontent les
meilleurs pâtissiers du monde au total
21 une équipe de troyes un pâtissier
d'un chocolatier et d'un glacier est
toujours le même objectif gagner ce
n'est au grenier des feuilles en sucre
au tir et angelo musi le pâtissier
capitaine de l'équipe de france a opté
pour du travail d'orfèvre
le thème de ces créations c'est le
fatigant mais pour le reste du royaume
le roman de trou aux fourneaux pendant
près de dix heures
ces spécialistes de la douceur sont
soumis à rude épreuve dans les
conditions qui sont pas c'est pas de
laboratoire les choses intimes des cours
du coup plus sceptiques qui fait chaud
au menu de cette coupe du monde
un entremets au chocolat un desserts
glacés aux fruits à une assiette
typiques de chaque pays compétiteurs des
oeuvres d'art qui vont devoir convaincre
les jurés des jurés à l'oeil et au papy
d'avertis ce sont les plus grands
pâtissiers du monde la valse des
assiettes et presque rituelle d'abord
l'observation une pâtisserie doit avoir
un look
ensuite le toucher et enfin bien entendu
la dégustation minutieuse et savante le
goût doit être à la fois agréable et
surprenant les allemands ont mis du
chili du piment avec le chocolat s'était
pas réalisé de façon extrêmement
harmonieuse dans la bouche mais c'était
vraiment intelligente et je pense que
c'est une excellente idée donc que pour
ça j'ai relevé la note de deux ou trois
points je pense que d'admettre du
caractère et de l'esprit dans un gâteau
c'est important des gâteaux qui se
change en sculpture une fois la
compétition passé et là encore personne
ne veut en perdre une miette